[Musique]
une vague de grippe des fermes sur le
pays bad ou raz de marée car le souvenir
des épidémies intérieur disparaît dans
ce concert général de toux et
d'éternuements les malades ne se
comptent plus on assiste dans tous les
domaines à une sorte de disparition
progressive de ce que la faculté nomme
line grippe à puce home aux lettres non
grippés qui pour se maintenir
doit d'ailleurs faire feu de tout bois
[Musique]
par contre les pharmaciens doit s'ouvrir
lâche bord car selon la plus abominable
des logiques
le malheur des uns continuent à faire le
bonheur des autres devant les
perspectives hallucinante de l'épidémie
les actualités françaises ont jugé de
leur devoir d'interroger le plus célèbre
des spécialistes le professeur qui est
un dac
monsieur le professeur que pensez-vous
de l'épidémie de grippe italienne et je
suis content résolument contre mais
d'ailleurs dès l'apparition des premiers
symptômes de cette grippe d'italiennes
jeudi voici leur donnant ce que vient
d'établir et qu'il faut faire exécuter
immédiatement par le pharmacien ou par
tout autre commerçant il faudra bien
s'en charger mais voilà primo sulfate de
parmesan râpé 125 g chlorhydrate de
gnocchi une pelletée uranium une libre
et nuit ortho base of any ni thomas
l'oni durée un saut fatal de vermicelles
un mètre carré une louche années sert à
chaque repas deuxièmement faire de
fréquents la maj d'intestin le troisième
en absorber le plus possible de vitamine
a ajouté nyan que la carotte contient
énormément de vitamine a il ya donc lieu
de brandebourg ou carottes oui elle
forme un lavage intestinaux mais les
salaires et non non mais c'est ok et
pendant ce temps là on pense à autre
chose à propos de peur que pensez-vous
des grog
bravo retient il faut prendre beaucoup
de bogues huit années grob par 24 heures
dans la propension de 10 gouttes d'eau
pour un livre de rome
ça lui permet saber salah ou gus et wes
à boma et tu quand c'est une croûte avec
moi au cusm web web
monsieur voudrait peut-être deux aph
monsieur fait son job parfaitement de
gens voudraient des offres et c'est le
plat même ou plutôt sur un plateau
volant comme vous emménagez sur un
plateau mais long way monsieur chat une
grande assiette qui soulève ah [ __ ]
met au dessus de la table pour faire
bien des heures la mire à quelle époque
mon violent quand et pour la mañana avec
leur système
abbas fait tout seul son camp in modo
relier ces écrans
et puis avec l'ensemble ouargla geler
l'aide de franchiseurs kobe 10 bat le
pinard t'as pu besoin d'elle mais talons
ben ouais bah moi aussi si c'était aux
armes là j'ai seulement moi je ne pense
pas qu'elle ait croûte suis un homme
d'intérieur
tiens tu ouest appareils incite à de la
poussière si ton tapis
tu laisses pire avec se situe leur bonne
puissance tulard pas un record avec ça
et si tu veux cci souhaite pp battu l'as
et ce toujours avec sa publicité comme
moi je t'aime
le beau linge propre tu fais cuire
tekken son étai saucette dans leur
machine à laver
puis alors ils ont des maîtres l'an dès
maintenant quitteront procès allait
année descoings s'est maintenant très
bas dans son qui a rien a souhaité céder
[Musique]
ce héros du conduite
c'est ce que vous risquez automobilistes
inexpérimentés qui venait de passer
votre permis à l'instar de pierre dac à
la veille des vacances
apprenez d'abord à connaître votre
propre voiture et ne confondez pas le
démarreur avec n'importe quel autre
bouton ou le frein avec l'accélérateur
un démarrage plus rapide sans
signalisation 0.8 ou doublé sur une
route glissante zéro de conduite de la
base enchaîne une voiture qui semble
ivre ou les consignes et on n'existait
pas zéro de conduite doublé en haut
d'une côte et marées on s'imagine au
kenya au monde qu'une seule voiture là
contre zéro de conduite oublier qu'il
existe aussi des cyclistes et des
cyclistes imprudents ses héros de
conduite ne pas se mettre en mode
éblouir d'autres conducteurs stationnés
sur la route sans feux de position au
zéro de conduite
on est à fond comme on dit le pied au
plancher
ce héros de conduite
et vous de tous et zéro de conduite la
conducteur novice vous en six
conducteurs expérimentés ils vous
mènerez loin au goût trop loin
[Musique]
il y à dents chez vous dès maintenant
c'est à dire oui ça va bien c'est ce qui
se passe là vous voyez vous savez que je
viens très souvent chez francis vient
aussi souvent chez moi travaillons bien
ensemble alors quand je viens ici je
partage mon temps
ça c'est une détente c'est très souvent
je reste des heures à la fenêtre
ah oui les yeux fixés sur la ligne bleue
de la place des vosges
mais il part et d'autre part je tricote
pour me détendre un peu du travail que
nous faisons
alors je m'entraîne en ce moment est ce
que vous faites comme java ça c'est un
entraînement c'est ça c'est un petit
paillasson fait mais c'est un
entraînement se prêtant à faire beaucoup
mieux
oui j'ai un truc là voyez vous dans un
magazine
l'élu de ces politiques d'ailleurs you
c'est le ce magazine sera magazine
prévient ses magazines de la femme sur
le retour et de la grand-mère déchaînés
c'est à dire et là il ya une recette de
tricot je vais arriver à faire ça débat
commode je voudrais vous donner cette
recette que j'espère faire d'ici
quelques jours quand je serai bien
d'entre eux n'est que j'aurai fini mon
paillasson
c'est un passe montagne de flash à
manches retroussées ses fantômes aux
affaires d'ailleurs les fournitures il
faut pour faire ça il faut qu'ils ont
marqué à 8 6 kg 750 de laine angora
torse analyse byfield cape town de
livrer mais de l'aide 24 fils colorés
aubergines tomates farcies et une pelote
basque de laine des pyrénées coloris
gitane berthod gauloises bleues savaient
déjà des sous ça les aiguilles ça s'est
passé les mêmes que ça oui la wii voit
sur des aiguilles les aiguilles 1.30 31
des habous renforcer alors les points il
faut pour faire le pas ce mot pen dont
on nous parle
il ya eu comme point il ya des points de
jersey de pointe qu'à deux points de
suspension pour les petits noeuds le
point sur la hanche pour l'empiècement
et le point de pitié pour les
emmanchures avant l'exécution qui est
assez compliquée
voilà vous montez 4 à 4 390 images et
vous ce côté 22 cm côté couture en khl
bourdon et 14 centimètres cubes en côtes
du rhône ou garnissez les en tant
qu'auto qu'andris vous rabattez dans le
milieu hui rang de chaque côté à raison
de 7 cm toutes les trois mois vous
travaillez simultanément la manche et en
terminant la fois en sens inverse
vous continuez en sortant deux mains et
toutes les cinq minutes
et ceci pendant 12 m ben oui bah oui
faut ça quoi
autant on arrivait à faire leur propre
quant à la finissent alors un mètre 75
du bas enfin du oui enfin du propre du
terme quoi lacie coat ont enfin baissé
de la lettre enfin je repense à mes 75
du shopi de bangui rabat et 224 maille
en diagonale ici x 78 mois et demi de
les renverser
alors là s'y prêtait alors là vous
n'avez plus qu'à diminuer les moyens au
fur et à mesure qu'elles sont et comment
les plus dingues c'est fini alors mais
alors qu'on annonce est à voir c'est
agréable parce que quand on arrive à
faire ça non seulement on n'a très jolie
passe montagne de plage à manches
retroussées mais ça peut également
servir de serpillière et 2 et 2 et
baguette de cuisine ou autre chose si on
veut enfin c'est bien je vais y arriver
sur la place des mots
voilà voilà ce que je suis obligé de
tailler voix
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs en
général ma soeur dernier né de la
technique expérimentale d'expression
scientifique d'avant-garde le big
l'autre on voit ci est un extraordinaire
appareils de synthèse dont la conception
révolutionnaire bouleverse de fond en
comble toutes les lois communément
admise tant dans le domaine de la
physique que thermonucléaire que dans
celui de la gynécologie dans l'espace
tel qu'il est le big l'autre en se
compose ou plus exactement se décompose
en trois circuits principaux dont deux
secondaire et dont voici par ordre
d'entrée en action le processus
fonctionnels de sa posologie caractériel
et fondamentale tout d'abord
d'abord on distingue le premier circuit
le oui c'est ça le club sourit deux
clubs soient ils qui isole et dupleix
l'entraînement par une armature ans
finit à bulot y diffuse asie par
capillarité médullaire sur le fil des
heures de télé et économétrie différé
lequel en vertu de phénomène d'osmose
ondulatoire dirigeants principe dans le
célèbre physicien jean-marie qu'est ce
que la boufballe catalyse en quelques
sortes le schpountz bulle de dérivation
et derrière lequel par voie de
conséquence se trouve entraînée par la
bûche miss asia spiroïdale en direction
de la zone d'affluence de la boue ce
type de rôle bail dont le tuyau d'agonie
aphonie spéculaire libère un certain
volume de la fnath paul lequel comme
chacun sait les autres qui a combiné de
ce mythe pu être l'état pur et de trop
feignants filtrant celle ci ferait bon
jusque là ça va ça va être un peu plus
compliqué dans le deuxième circuit de le
même mouvement s'opère mais en sens
inverse il donc il il en parlait même à
voix basse d'autant que c'est le
troisième circuit que se trouve
étroitement conjuguer les éléments
majeurs de mériter parmi lesquels le ch
maximum rotatif à travailler
il dans le rôle de générateur permanent
est prépondérant piste par le simple
truchement de son ennui de gicler il
polit popur hypothèse littéralement le
filtre envolée qu'il bute en lequel en
dernière la lys détermine l'angle
orbiculaire et signaux idal du foot us
le bonheur est à spirales intro plus
réactionnaires parallèlement qu'enfin le
fleuve et le fleuve du métronome lab se
dit naturellement
autrement ça n'aurait aucun sens le feu
n'est donc prenant appui sur la mue est
de l'allergie du connecteur à rustiques
de distorsion et morineau statique
canalise une part l'afflux des
particules est paumé faisceau loide et
d'autre part le reflux indexer des
molécules ip à son froc rideau d'eau
élimination positive de toute
interférence parasitaire puisque
l'ensemble de la ville hommage sur 10
circuits et en dernier ressort quasi
simultanément contrôlée par
l'amplificateur de roanne et par
l'utilisation rationnelle dans la belle
et leurs pinceaux maîtrise de la force
extra fins d'arrêt dicté laquelle codes
du de dior est proportionnelle au carré
des angles tu as l'air d'un
concentriques télé dans ses lignes
essentielles le big lots seront que les
plus hautes autorités scientifiques
internationales s'accordent à
reconnaître qu'on n'a plus étonnant des
découvertes de tous les temps et y dans
un avenir d'autant plus proche qui sera
moins éloignés est appelée non seulement
à servir à tout ce qui est la moindre
des choses mais encore et surtout à
n'importe quoi y compris tout ce qui en
découle sans préjudice du reste
et le tout ce qui s'ensuit
à
oui cette table est libre oui à table et
sa chaise
c'est haussier d'hier baisse est heureux
parce qu'avoir un servi la libération si
elle évolue finalement voyons bond à 8 m
et ben voilà vingt points n'est plus
libre allez babala excusez-moi de vous
dévisagent est un peu cavalièrement
monsieur mais descendu de cheval
monsieur j'ai l'impression de l'avoir
déjà rencontrée quelques pas assez bien
possible j'y vais régulièrement
ah bah moi aussi je suis dans le même
cas vous voyez vous ah ben ça doit être
là enfin entre nouveau mieux deux hommes
de même qu'aucun sur les mers la voyons
ou 3 ou 3 dans le pétrin oui ou quatre
dans la cua dans la même situation
critique
mabri bon on peut pas vous
on passait pas à bobino 120 grands music
hall de la mjc c'est n'est ce pas on est
bien là c'est là que je vous ai vu on va
dépasser aussi vous verrez c'est curieux
c'est vous qui vous marrer comme une
baleine voyez vous comme deux blessés ça
fait le poids ouais les toits et du
'journal s'annonce pas très bien en ce
moment non ben c'est pas encourageant ah
non non plus mettre mes lunettes parce
que j'en ai besoin d acheter aux
annonceurs oui ça s'appelle de fou de
l'argent des notes par les fenêtres en
ce moment j'aime bien ces lunettes
ménage sa monture à la voilà voilà
il sait pas brillante dans le même les
prévisions météorologiques ce n'est rien
d'extraordinaire c'est pas vrai
d'ivoire que vous voyez vous voyez c'est
désolant sa de rassurant à menaçant ah
oui c'est les prévisions météorologiques
pour les pour les pour le prochain
week-end mais les fêtes de pâques et les
prochaines fêtes foraines de rassurant à
menaçant de menaces en a pas bien beau
ne pas bien moi plutôt moche est plutôt
moche a franchement tarte s'est pas
préparé pour vous rassure pas brillant
il ya ciel généralement couvert sur un
ensemble de pays avec on peut appeler
belles éclaircies lui permettant de se
découvrir respectueusement devant les
cortèges et les défilés de cumulus de
cumulonimbus d'alto stratus de cyrus de
ses pitreries sens douzy la suite russo
épiler les températures possibles et
probables
ah oui oui pour les régions noratlas une
aviation est républicain ouest
démocratique centre gauche et centre
droit sous le bras 37,5 sous la langue
38,2 ailleurs suivant le cas oui bah oui
oui le buy in est donné dans les wallons
bien sûr et bon oui enfin du point
tout ça c'est très joli mais voit ça
avec le changement de gouvernement en
tant qu'île même d'ailleurs le percement
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
situation actuelle map 11 passes
oui bien sûr c'est s'il vient tout de
suite à l'esprit marie mai mais quand
même quand on y réfléchit
quand on va au fond des choses oui on
corrige que d'y rester
oui et pour en sortir oui c'est toute
l'histoire est toute une affaire
et enfin c'est comme ça et pas autrement
elle même et comme disait celui qui ne
voit plus rien à dire vaut mieux c'est
oui ouais bon moi je cois je me demande
où je vous vous habitez le quartier
ouais j'avais trop 121 avenue du
commandant jonathan des renforts
arrivent de tananarive
c'est bien comme cartier ses centrales
louis fleury pour le brave et aurions
bien sûr vous habitez dans un léger s
ennuyait chicoine jsk dira un immeuble à
grand standing à l' on note chez lui
qu'est ce que c'est que ça une
habitation à loyer modéré
c'est bien que l'état joue êtes au 20e
nous avons une belle vue de la tribu
avaient imprenable ça donne sur quoi sur
un sur un immeuble administratif de 32
étages on va vous êtes tranquille là
c'est calme au moins ah oui oui foot
auriez la personne du tout prix alors
c'est aujourd'hui alors ils ont été nous
avez quoi dans votre appartement comme
après ben ali à une entrée encore rick
acabit ont garni et un en avant première
des serres de café l'addition
oui le service découvert compris oui
vous avez une terrasse à l'ombre en
terrasse ou un grand père c'est agréable
après erreur oui parce que ça me permet
de faire un peu d'élevage à vous élever
oui vous avez quoi des poules des lapins
des escargots mans et chevaux des
chevaux à bascule quand terrasses
balcons terrasses les voisins du dessous
sont agréables mais pas encore ceux qui
rouspètent personne ne se plaint quand
même quand vous allez faire une marche
d'entraînement vers minuit et que vous
rentrez avec tous vos shows dans la
maison ça doit en panne ont d'abord son
défaut bien élevé au 20e pour en
découvrir
puis alors je l'aurais après ils sont
éduqués en avoir oui ils disent pas en
passant de rancière de leader eni soit
qui mal y pense comme vous dites c'est
bien sûr et puis la violence virtuelle
en sabots en plus ce sont des jaloux
trop de bruit des chevaux bien élevé
très bien élu et c'est ce qu'il y en a
qui seraient capables de faire les
livraisons tout seul à paris or pourquoi
pas et vous habitez du corps
port-cartier banlieue où seul un petit
et un petit coin charmant un missile et
de pologne mais il vous voyez c'est un
très joli par habitant le val de grâce
de marne val de grâce demain c'est
charmant c'est charmant
il avait un pavillon dans un pavillon
devant le pavillon bain un pavillon de
la marine marchande à dammarie morceaux
et marine nationale la marine de guerre
a naturellement tous les matins ou fait
salut aux couleurs
non non non je tire à tout galure au
marchand de couleurs en face ils ont
bien même bien son charmant e semaine
mieux mais les bombes élite bolt ans
avance mais nous avons encore beaucoup
de choses à nous dire
on rit ça serai demain je suis content
d'avoir bavarder donc
elle va aussi va alors peut-être
pourrions-nous prendre pour prendre cet
entretien tout de suite un prochain
rendez vous il faut qu'on soit là
prenons le tout de suite ghaleb la wii
bah oui quand voulez-vous bas quand vous
voudriez bon et où ça où vous voudrez
bon ok le vôtre sera la mienne bas j'y
serai là moi aussi vous êtes concentré
je suis concentré
vous êtes conseil lait concentré comme
on dit chez next et alors je vais vous
demander votre cellulite et de me dire
qu'elle et les cylons dia cale de
monsieur monsieur et des sous le double
signe de la cale du lion et du
fonctionnel de écrit il et son caractère
impulsif et simultanées oui ils sont à
venir
monsieur a son avenir devant lui mais il
aura dans le dos chaque fois qu'ils
vendent mais tous il est génial
une absolument génial voulez-vous me dis
là plaisr il est lucide yakin de
mademoiselle est né sous le triple signe
bénéfiques de la vierge du taureau et du
sagittaire avant de s'en servir
quel est son avenir conjugale et
prolifique prolifique non à des enfants
oui et des jumelles et jumelles combien
une paire voilà avec avec l'aco a été
tué et le merveilleux le voit tout il
sait tout bon c'est l'unité voulez-vous
me dire la plaisance est calé
akale de monsieur leptine mercurochrome
quelles sont ses goûts et messieurs les
goûts sportifs sportif quel est son
sport préféré je pense qu ça il peut le
pratiquer sans inconvénients oui à
condition toutefois de se méfier se
méfier de qui de quoi
le cinquième personne dans son entourage
qui pourrait penser que sa compétence
dans le domaine de la [ __ ] pourra-t-il
gers et n'influence fâcheuse ce son
contentement sentimentale et qu'est ce
que vous lui conseiller lui conseille de
changer de braquet et surveillés sur
l'île en évidence avec des hostilités à
présent dites moi et quelle est la
taille de monsieur 1 m 78 debout m 56
ainsi avec 45 à plat ventre et 0 mètre
quatre-vingt deux roulés en boule à
relever et il pèse combien de fois par
mois si l'idée d'une main ou de mal son
poids est rixe
je ne parle pas bien français 78 kg sans
eau sans d'alison d'électricité oui quel
est son degré d'instruction secondaire
il a des diplômes
oui monsieur licenciés licenciés ils
changent cgc qui signifie il travaille
au gain lafayette et qu'on l'a foutu à
la porte à présent profiter
vous me direz vous dit combien madame
at-elle dedans rentrer dedans et de ne
s'est pas fait vous me direz
quelle est la nationalité de madame en
fait il est son père eskimos et sa mère
pochette surprise et sa soeur d'un char
et bâle beurre quand va t on enfin
baguette moi c'est pas beau oui aux
insolences oublie mal élevés escrocs
rega s'ils étaient concentrés vous un
peu je vous trouve bien dilué tout à
chaleur qui fait pas étonnant pour ses
idées est-ce que je peux continuer à
vous poser des questions ou des ventes
aussi c'est l'unité et messieurs que
voici que voilà at il des complexes
oui monsieur besoins complexes tel
complexe certains moments il prend sa
vessie pour une lanterne et alors et
loris brûle au cdr ans et demi à présent
quelque chose de ttt très important
pouvez-vous dire le numéro de la carte
d'identité de monsieur oui vous pouvez
le dire
oui vous pouvez le dire oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]